- Hi, Drew.
I heard that you liked my DIY TV frame,
and so here are my
step-by-step instructions
on how to do it.
You buy baseboard molding
and then cut it at 45 degrees
to the size of your TV and
spray paint the pieces.
You get wood appliques and
spray paint those as well.
Put your frame together
and add corner braces.
Add hanging hardware.
And I decided to add this
step of more definition
by adding crown molding trim.
I cut those at 45 degrees,
added them onto the inside of my frame,
and I then just spray
painted that as well.
I added an extra step
of putting Rub 'n Buff
for the antique gold finished look.
Here's where I mount the frame,
put the TV on the TV mount,
and the final step is
adding some gold washi tape
around the edge of the frame.
This way, you get rid of the
black frame around your TV
and your remote sensor will still work,
and it blends seamlessly
with your new gold frame.